Hey, everybody.
Welcome here to a beautiful day in San Francisco.
We're on the roof of the Moscone center.
I know we showed you something really special
yesterday.
And we got so much interest that we wanted
to show you how we put it all together.
And, actually, we wanted to show you some
of the pretty same exciting action that you
saw, but from a new perspective this time.
So you can see, this is the roof.
Some of our bikers are warming up out there.
And they're doing some of their cool tricks,
getting ready for their part of this demonstration.
You can also see that the airship is actually
overhead.
You might be able to see it through my view
through my Glass in the Hangout.
And we actually have a number of the jumpers
in the Hangout now.
Now, as I walk over here, you'll see that
it's actually tricky to keep them in the Hangout
because of the really challenging wireless
environment.
>>Sergey Brin: And if I can show you all on
here, we're pointing each of these dishes,
using different kinds of RF technology for
redundancy.
Each jumper has a different piece of technology
coming down.
And that's how we felt comfortable that we
could maintain at least a couple of them in
the Hangout.
I'm also, by the way, testing out a new kind
of iteration of Glass with these shade clip-ins
here right now.
And they're -- definitely makes it better
out here in the bright sun.
So we're going to have -- we've worked, you
know, with a lot of people around here, with
the City of San Francisco, the FAA, and the
municipal offices of Oakland and San Jose
to make this happen.
But the coordination is pretty tricky, as
you might imagine.
Let’s see.
Our jump master is here.
This is Marshal.
Marshal, how far out are we?
>>> We’re under two minutes from the wing
suits being in the air.
>>Sergey Brin: We’re under two minutes?
Ok.
That's super exciting.
And you guys might be able to see their perspectives
right now in the Hangout live.
This is pretty exciting to me.
How's -- have you heard from J.T.?
How are they doing up there?
>>> They're in position right now.
They're going to hover a little while, open
the door, they're going to fly in their wing
suits northwest of us here, deploy their parachutes.
And then you and I will be out here and it
will be high fives and smiles when they land.
>>Sergey Brin: Alright awesome.
Since we only have a couple minutes, why don't
you guys walk with me.
I want to get closer to their landing zone.
And, you know, as we go here, I can just point
out, I mean, it's just stunning here.
But if you look over there, as we walk toward
the landing zone, you can see a fog bank right
over there.
And that fog bank is actually very scary to
us.
It seems to be clearing out, so we feel good
about the jump today.
But there was no guarantee.
And, in fact, I should note that skydiving,
you know, there's no such thing as instrument
skydiving.
You actually have to see your landing.
Though I guess, conceivably, with Glass, you
could make an instrument version.
You have a nice heads-up display where you're
going.
>>Sergey Brin: But, anyway, we'll have to
try that another time.
I know, I'm scaring my jump master.
Today, we have sunny skies.
You can see -- there's the airship pretty
much straight overhead.
I don't know if we can get -- maybe we'll
get another shot of that.
We have a few cameras scattered here that
can show you that.
And let's keep walking here.
A lot of exciting action.
Now, I don't want to -- I don't want to block
your view.
Hopefully, the audience is seeing right now
-- how is our Hangout going?
>>> We're ready to go up to the airship.
>>> Okay.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
They're ready to jump.
Cool.
How's our view in the Hangout coming along?
>>> I think J.T. is ready.
Go up to J.T.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
That's so cool.
Why don't we throw it up to J.T. and he can
take it away.
And, hopefully, this Hangout will go as well
as yesterday did.
But, you know, you never know.
A million things can go wrong.
Okay, take it away, J.T.
>>> Yeah.
Good to be here, Terry.
Yeah, lucky with that fog.
Good job calling ahead on that one, Sergey.
And Marshal, who's going to run the countdown?
Neal, on the airship is going to be counting
down.
The door is open.
>>> Good morning, San Francisco!
Hey, how are the winds doing down there?
All right.
Well, we're going for it.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
We've got 30 seconds, everyone.
I'm super excited about this.
>>> See you in a few.
>>Sergey Brin: Airship is almost straight
overhead.
It's a beautiful day.
We're really lucking out that the fog is holding
back.
Door is open.
Pretty much standing still right now.
>>> Just going that way.
God, that --
>>Sergey Brin: That must be a beautiful feeling
to just fly right out of there.
>>> Five, four, three, two, one!
>>> Jumping away.
>>Sergey Brin: There they are!
There they are!
You can see them flying.
>>Sergey Brin: They're soaring across the
sky.
Look at that.
They're weaving closely in and out of each
other.
The Hangout footage, I'm sorry, I don't have
it.
It must be beautiful.
Their chutes are opening.
We've got two chutes open.
And the third one, with a puff of smoke, just
opened.
If you're wondering why, we had to put one
of them with a puff of smoke so the radio-aiming
folks could know which skydiver was theirs.
>>> Walk over here and -- we'll try to give
them high fives as they land.
>>Sergey Brin: Yes, if we can get over this
way pretty quick, and, hopefully, you guys
can tag along.
Okay, bikers ready.
You can see we're getting ready.
Skydivers coming down.
All right.
Where should I stand here?
>>> Going to land right --
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
You can see them clearly.
You can now --
>>> Give us 30 meters out.
>>Sergey Brin: All right.
>>> Step right over here.
They're going to be landing, coming towards
us.
>>> Here comes J.T. right here.
>>> All right.
>>Sergey Brin: Woo-hoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>> Yeah, buddy.
Yeah, all right!
[ Applause ]
>>Sergey Brin: Incoming.
>>> Whoa all right!
Nice!
>>Sergey Brin: That was awesome.
>>> Thanks for having us.
>>Sergey Brin: Thanks for coming down.
All right.
That was amazing.
>>> Good job.
>>Sergey Brin: All of our jumpers are down.
And they make it look so easy.
All right.
Don't get blown away here.
Hey, hey, that was great.
Thanks, again.
Amazing jump.
Thanks, guys.
>>> That was awesome.
>>Sergey Brin: Great job.
All right, thanks, guys, so much.
Now, don't forget, we tested -- that was an
amazing jump.
We have more in store to show you just how
did we do the rest of it.
We have our excellent bikers here.
And this is a really fun area here.
There are a few kind of natural blocks and
things.
But the killer thing that we put in there,
because the roof goes up and down, there's
a really great ramp that we put in there.
And that was where you saw that magical moment.
So maybe we can actually get a chance to see
the bikers -- let's see what you guys got!
All right.
And we're going to try to make our way so
we can first of all watch this.
Watch this.
Yeah!
Whoa, another back flip.
That was amazing.
All right.
We're going to head over now and try to catch
them on the other side.
The roof goes, actually, up, and then there's
the giant dropoff on the other side.
So here we are.
And -- actually, it's kind of cool, because
I don't know if you guys can see me right
now.
I'm now in a Hangout.
Back on the other side, had a little bit of
issues keeping me in the Hangout.
But here it's working nicely.
And it's a -- I mean, I know they make it
look easy.
But they're probably, what, 15 feet up there?
And they're going to just show us how they
get down off that big ramp.
All right, guys.
Let's see you go.
>>> Go, go, go!
>>> They're hitting the drop.
>>> All right.
See you down there.
>>Sergey Brin: You can see that they're -- we've
got three, actually.
And it's a long way down.
It's a long way down.
I'm actually going to take off my Glass so
you can see this.
Okay.
Now, hopefully, they've made it down safe
and sound.
Thank you, all, for watching.
I know we have a lot of interest.
And we just wanted to show for the people
who just, you know, heard about it just yesterday,
want to show you about something that it took
and actually show you some of that amazing
action again.
All right.
Well, we'll keep you abreast of our progress
on Glass.
This is just one of the exciting things that
we've had the privilege of working on and
that -- I'm hoping this is going to lead to
something really exciting going forward.